I mean the the strange thing is the way
that Moscow related to the West for all
those years under Soviet communism was
driven by ideology
a cold war was The Clash of political
social systems and beliefs
um but now it seems much more driven by
self-interest so um Putin's opposition
to the West seems to stem from
the personal hurt that he felt at the
end of the Soviet Union which he took
really as a sort of personal humiliation
yeah and it seems to me that he's spent
20 years with that hurt festering inside
him and it's finally overflowed in
February this year and
but it's it's from within him and people
like him
um and it's very personal for Putin
because it's it isn't an ideology driven
conflict however much he pretends it is
it's very personal and it's kind of
financial as well because he's a man who
spent a long time enriching himself from
State monies in Russia uh money that
should have been spent on roads and
infrastructure and Health Service and
pensions and you can only do that for a
certain length of time before people
start to get upset with that so if
you're a dictator and you're worried
that you're in the eye of the storm and
people may be moving against you what's
the standard response it's start a war
isn't it so you know if we look at the
wars that he started they all seem to
have coincided with Plunge in his
popularity rating so 2008 he was
very unpopular
so he invaded Georgia 2014 again his
ratings were plummeting and he moved
into Crimea next Crimea Crimea and in
the run-up to 2022 this year what was
happening in navoni was coming back
um discontent was you know overflowing
onto the streets and so what again is
his response it's you know to start a
war I remember in at the end of 1991
when George Bush Senior made his
New Year address to the American people
it was like a sort of baseball coach
who'd won the World Series because his
whole take on the collapse of the Soviet
Union was that we did it you know we
Americans have stood up to this
Dreadful communist system for 70 years
but now it's gone it's a time for
American values and it wasn't I mean the
the collapse of the Soviet Union came
from within within the Soviet Union and
I think that's the mentality that now
communism has gone we can forget about
Russia was the way that the West
approached Russia for the next 10 years
at least and probably more that we
solved that problem we don't need to
worry about it anymore
um but they'd forgotten that the victors
are on a pretty Sticky Wicket if they
start preaching to the vanquished and
and the Americans did that and a lot of
people in the west did that politicians
in the west did that
um and I don't know there was naivety or
it was just sort of um Blind Faith that
you know Russia would change and become
something it hadn't been for a thousand
years
um
I don't want to say that you know the
reason Putin is now so anti-western is
the fault of the West because it's the
fault of Putin and it's the fault of the
people around Putin but the West maybe
didn't help in the way that it treated
uh Putin and people like him after the
collapse of the Soviet Union